did you did you see that uh um ted lou
tweeted at uh ron desantis or whatever
and he's like it's not hard just to
condemn nazis ron i saw that now it's
just like
at this point
i don't think there is any unaffiliated
person who is sitting there going like
wow ron desantis wouldn't condemn nazis
he must be raised no no i'm sorry at
this point everyone's either like i know
he's not but i'm going to call him that
anyway or they support him and they say
we know you're just lying yeah
there's where is the where is the person
confused about this i think what's going
on though and i think a lot of people
are missing this is that in all the talk
about ron desantis 2024 will iran won't
he run is he going to go against trump
et cetera et cetera a lot of what's been
missing in that conversation is that ron
desantis is up for re-election this year
in florida and so people are missing the
fact that you are going to get psyopped
by the media and by the left like you've
never seen before in florida now
remember ron only won by like one point
right the last time around in 2018 now
he he wasn't as much of a household name
back then as he is now his approval
ratings are much much higher and so
obviously with the mood of the country
he should do quite well but they are
going to throw the absolute gauntlet at
ron desantis so they're going to go this
is just the start this is just the start
of it they find some crazy group on the
side of the road
you are going to see a complete unleash
on ron desantis and that's going to be
the test run for 2024 maybe maybe
but the one thing stopping ron desantis
from a potential 2024 run is that he is
the governor of florida and a lot of
people want him to stay there because
he's more effective than he would be as
president if they come at him and they
actually end up winning florida then
desantis could run in 2024.
maybe that's good for republicans and
populists or or maybe you're right and
maybe what they want to do is they want
they want to take the governorship from
him so that he says okay well now i'm
free to run in 2024 and create a rift
between him and the trump and trump and
the support and the base and maybe
that's you know chaos strategy they will
do anything they can to split up the
populist movement you're seeing them
already do this you're seeing people who
are just spread you're going to see like
ron by the way
what's the biggest right to the main the
main argument for ron desantis and i'm i
don't have like a dog in this fight i'm
not arguing one way or the other but the
main idea is they say well trump has
baggage and ron doesn't and and and ron
is effective and you know people get
turned off when they hear about trump
but with ron he doesn't have that stuff
the point is to give him the baggage now
they want to bloody him up and dirty him
up and destroy his wikipedia page and do
anything they can to just put as many
marks on this guy before 2020. i i think
we have deeper problems than that that i
don't
i don't know if that's going to matter
as much i'm sure obviously it won't
matter but i hope it doesn't
this this country is so hyper polarized
i don't know how much more we can
withstand
you you can go on look at project
veritas i mean james o'keefe is getting
more and more popular among regular
people i went to uh a little farm nearby
in fact we have a little alpaca behind
lily sitting right here that we we we
put up every so often and it looks just
like retracto i thought it was retracted
it is not it just looks like it and we
were out i was at this little farm
um just a little farm not super
political people and we were just
talking about regular stuff and they
were fairly moderate and then i
mentioned i think we had just had like
james o'keefe on the show this was a few
months ago and then peop
there's a guy in the store and the woman
they're both like we love james o'keefe
and i was like really and they were like
yes they were like you know we're sick
of the manipulation the lies he does
great work
when i when i i heard that
and we're in like a moderate area it's
like decently blue and and we're like
we're not far from dc so it's fairly
mixed politically
but with all of the smears they've
thrown at him with his wikipedia page
being completely fictitious nonsensical
op-eds saying project veritas is
far right racist conspiracy whatever
the the the narrative control is gone do
you see what they're doing now on
wikipedia there's actually an argument
right now on wikipedia apparently
there's a page called the um the
massacres of communism and they want to
delete it there's actually an argument
about deleting that page because they're
trying and they're trying to say this
stuff about oh well this this was
unintentional this was just what do they
say in china the famine years the three
years of famine
three years of natural natural disasters
right natural disasters my point is just
it's ineffective
the all the smears they've thrown in
them and still regular people down the
street are big fans of his they they
didn't know who i was they didn't watch
the show they didn't listen to podcasts
but they were familiar with with project
veritas and they loved it i mean look at
the epstein expose that veritas did with
uh amy rorbach or whatever her name is
robert the biggest story they've ever
done they they get a leaked video of abc
basically saying they had witness
testimony about epstein that there was
that was that was shut down and that's
project veritas doing that
they're not only putting out partisan
information but i use james o'keefe as
an example
that you know when you mention ron
desantis and his wikipedia page and
trying to smear him i'm like i don't
know if that matters anymore i think i
think well it's not just the wikipedia
though and that's not that's part of it
but it's the idea is it's the steady
drum beat and it's going to you know
first it's the nazis on the side of the
road what happens when there's they
still haven't caught the pipe bomber
from january
what happens when there's more stuff
like that that goes on in i'm telling
you they're gonna throw
so the regime is gonna do anything they
can to take out someone they view but
it's like a person in quicksand
thrashing violently and sinking faster
for doing it you look at what they said
we we covered this the other day talking
about the great honking the toronto sun
was like the trucker protest that are a
bunch of far-right racist nazi
flag-waving people who stole food from
the homeless and we're just like was
just that one
yeah like columnist that one crazy
columnist guy who was right well they
were like trudeau said it well like
these people just got in a truck one
morning and you're like you know we're
gonna mess with homeless people today
that's our whole cause like to hear the
media characterize them that's what
you'd think it was like you know hey i'm
going to go be racist with my fellow
truckers like they have no other
motivation but besides trying to be
horrible
minority they call this this this
massive convoy which is now spreading
all these other cities which may be
spreading to the us i'm just saying i
feel like we are winning and by we it's
it's such a massive and eclectic
political group i mean you've got
post-liberal i guess they call it people
who used to be your traditional liberal
not finding themselves politically
homeless or more aligned with
conservatives simply because they agree
on fundamental human rights you've got
libertarians all of a sudden agreeing
with conservatives on a bunch of issues
and it's because the establishment and
the left are so insane that all these
other groups have basically been like
hey can we can we band together because
they've lost their minds right the time
for talk and
time to discuss sometimes just becomes
so hard to find now peacefully i really
prefer we use our constitutional
republic system to choose your truly
represented representative in dc so we
don't have to use our second amendment
of course that's something you cannot
compromise that's our last resort to
fight for freedom but the same time
every year you have local time election
for school board for other council
meetings seated seats and then every two
years you have congressional elections
people just have to
get out of their comfort zone to take
action so if you just keep your head
down i can't guarantee you it's not
going to be over they will continue to
push it the communists will
come to test your limits and will take
your freedom away i i
you know when it comes to second
amendment stuff i i don't think i have
the same opinion as a lot of people who
think you know
you know one day you'll need to stand up
for your rights and it's like yeah
but hold on
yes
but this trucker convoy is just a bunch
of people driving their trucks and look
how much they've accomplished and are
accomplishing peaceful protests work
these times that's right in fact uh i've
said it we're not in that era anymore
where standing in a building gains you
political power you know was it with
january 6 it's like what do you think it
is 1700s you stand in the building like
aha we have the building it's ours now
and i don't know what that's going to do
in a digital era but if tomorrow
every single person in new york city
said there is no vaccine mandate then
there wouldn't be one and you know the
you know the new mayor or whatever
politicians can say no no no but what we
said and everyone would still like i
shut up yeah then there would be none so
if it's not even necessarily about
non-violent civil disobedience or
protest it's about the will of the
people and what they're truly willing to
do non-compliance i mean look at it this
way
speed limit
can't go more than five miles over the
speed limit that's a ticket literally
everyone does
so therefore it's effectively
unenforceable in in in many ways you
might get singled out but depending on
where your jurisdiction is you typically
you're going to be like your house is
like four miles over the limit he's
gonna get in my courtroom you know what
i mean so cultural enforcement is the
main is the main issue we need to strive
for and that's why when i look at the
failures of the attempts at smearing
when i look at the ratings collapse of
cnn when i look at the massive
popularity of shows like joe rogan i'm
like we win the message we win
everything this is also all the marbles
this is also why the
trucker uprising
is such an inflection point right now
because you're also kind it's also
relevatory in a sense because they are
actually taking action that is
threatening to the regime um they are
quite literally holding up the backbone
of our society and they are preventing
the supply chains from being continued
in certain areas and in key areas but
you're noticing though and i can look
around
there's lots of people who run around
calling themselves populist leaders you
see as a populist right populist left
calling them conservatives
who aren't supporting the truckers or
who are running around this is by the
way why aaron o'toole who's the leader
of the conservative party in canada
right now just as an example he's
certainly not the only one they're
actually saying talking about
taking him taking away the head of the
party from him because he's just not
doing much to support the truckers and i
think this is absolutely revelatory
situation where
this is a litmus test actually right now
that if you are not actively supporting
the truckers then what are you doing
right really what what else are you
doing other than saying i need to
support these guys because they are
taking action that's being effective in
real time it's peaceful it's fun they
turned it into a rave in ottawa right
they're not yeah okay maybe there's like
one or two nut jobs who show up where
you know the guy's got a mask on
carrying a confederate flag you know
who's he threw him out right they threw
him out so how many people are actually
gonna be showing the most powerful video
that came out today was rebel media when
they showed the mounties the royal
canadian mounted police walking away
they were given the enforcement rule to
go in and start arresting people and
they stood down they can't do it
you know i remember during occupy wall
street you've got how many how many
millions of people in manhattan on the
isla on the island i think it's like two
million
and then uh or or somewhere around there
and then the entirety of new york city
the five boroughs is i think what like
seven or nine million or some
ridiculously large number
and i was telling you know how many how
many nypd cops are there thirty thousand
forty thousand
there are not enough cops to actually
stop a seriously large populist uprising
like during the mayday protests there
was something like a hundred thous this
is back directly there's like a hundred
thousand people in 2012 marching down
broadway and if all of them decided to
just break social norms and go full
antifa city's gone
there's no way they'd have to call the
national guard and they probably
wouldn't even be able to get enough
national garden you get to a point where
you have 50 000 truckers
what do you do you're going to send in
some mounties start arresting them one
by one you don't have the resources to
stretch the 50 miles to actually do that
they can't do anything well did we did
we even talk about the the tow truck
companies yet no no well that tim too oh
well let's uh yeah yeah yeah well i
don't do do you have the story i don't
know if you wanna pull it up no i don't
know where to find it i just wanted to
say too here that this is uh the fact
that they can't enforce it is another
reason why it's so important to them to
set the narrative they want you to be
opposed to this group they want to turn
the entire public against them because
they know there's no way they're going
to be able to enforce their will well i
want to say something that lots of
people
because they living fair they bought
into the rhetoric's government and the
media they feel like oh government is
good for public
health yes and for society and broader
common good but that's exactly same
thing commonly sold us in china it's for
public good you don't have gun rights
because without the ccp the china will
be totally collapsed
and we're not capable of democracy
either like taiwan people because
without ccp
there's no stability it it's there are
two rules of propaganda number one part
is always right always right number two
all the medias all they press repeat
same lies every day by lots of people
you become the truth so i have to thank
you tim you and your all those
alternative comedians and jack you you
are bring truth to people and and you
trust people to decide and i'm just
trying to wake up people to say
stay away from the media go to
alternative media and truth should give
you the power and to set you free
and that way you can understand what is
government day now oh government is not
just a requirement it's a force if they
mandate something you don't follow
you'll get fined if you don't pay your
fine you're going to go to locked up
you're going to lose your job you're
going to stay home look what happened to
australia right it's just people have to
understand government represents force
against the regular citizens you can
choose to get a vaccine but if you force
somebody get a vaccine
what what is the freedom about if you
cannot even control what this goes
inside your body as medicine that's
fundamental human rights so all those
leftists support human rights should
understand that government is false let
people decide amen so thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you